you can subscribe to the spectator for
12 weeks for only 12 pounds
for our print and online editions plus
get six months of digital access
free to the telegraph go to spectator
dot co dot uk
forward slash telegraph
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
the podcast from the spectator where we
pick a few of our writers each week
to get them to read their pieces out for
you this week we'll be joined by
comedian grifforce jones
who talks about how london has become a
war zone for motorists
also on the episode this week toby young
on why he's become an english
nationalist
and at the very end cosmo landersman on
the joyce of drinking alone
first graff rhys jones late one evening
in yangon in myanmar a few years ago i
noticed a grey morris minor van
patrolling the streets
it had an old-fashioned double-ended
trumpet loud speaker on its roof
blaring out an amplified voice
what's it saying i asked my guide
it tells the people it's late stop
drinking
and go to bed you have a busy day
tomorrow
she told me that's the spirit
we should get some of that in london
stop eating
get on your bikes pedal faster
why has kovid brought out a rash of
virtuous
bullying i've lost count of the number
of times that radio
4 has asserted that this plague will
create a better
more caring more aware lovelier human
race
and if not we can of course
be ordered to be so now
in the middle of calamity as we try to
save a faltering economy halt the return
of a deadly pandemic
and resume normality transport for
london
tfl in league with earnest local
councillors and encouraged by the
government
have decided to take this moment to
force londoners
to adopt a more worthy form of personal
transport they've arbitrarily closed off
park lane houston road the edgeware road
and hundreds of other main arteries
their world leading street space for
london
will stop rat runs and make london
areas access only
a how these
are the main roads
you may love all this if you're fit and
20 the elderly think it's bonkers
ordinary working people with jobs and
cars are simply confused
i'm not anti-bike i love them
i love mine so much that in the early
1970s i was just about the only bloke
on a bicycle in central london also it
felt
i used to haul it into the back of a
black cab particularly
if i was a little drunk and unwilling to
face the back wind
of articulated trucks in a rainstorm
bikes are more popular now but
they're still a limited enthusiasm
these days however minority zeal
is our master mount up buster
you're either with us or you are with us
well not the nine o'clock news 40 years
ago mel smith played a man
on a phone doodling on an envelope
hanging up
he handed the squiggles over as the new
one-way system
for basildon this comic creation
is now at work at tfl putting in bicycle
lanes that end abruptly and arbitrarily
and closing roads everywhere with
planters
modal filters copenhagen crossings and
experimental traffic orders
in may the mayor of london sadiq khan
and tfl
launched this bold new street space
plan to rapidly transform london streets
to accommodate
a possible tenfold increase in cycling
and five-fold increase in walking when
lockdown restrictions are eased
they have reduced the real traffic to a
long
honking choked pipe of polluting
fumes while cyclists weave in and out
scrupulously avoiding the new lanes
i rarely drive in london i live in the
middle of all this and walk everywhere
but the other week i got into my mobile
hazcam sealed unit
my car and i ventured out into the
extraordinary new setup
along the houston road i confronted
vast pavement spaces to enable the
non-existent central london workforce
to keep yards apart on their way to
those
packed basement restaurants and pubs and
a lane to facilitate an imaginary horde
of new bikes
with another garage way taken over to
allow the occasional
vacant bus to belch past every
construction vehicle
van and rig in london was now creeping
along a narrow
gut spewing out particulate
matter even if there was
a tenfold increase in cycling which
there wasn't
central london is already over provided
with lanes
how do i know this because the crazy
golf shoots are generally empty
why first because the lanes jump around
all over the place
they disgorge the law abiding into
dangerous
intersections and secondly you can't
overtake everybody knows
that half the cyclists in london think
they're in a race
bicycle accidents increased by 57
after the introduction of the tavistock
torrington placed lane
every sane cyclist already uses the back
roads
for their daily commute motorized
traffic
won't diminish it will head for these
back roads too exactly as i did
it may not mount the pavements and zip
up one-way
streets like any self-respecting bicycle
boy but it will pollute
the very places where central londoners
live
we only have a rush hour because central
london councils
want one a good proportion of their
housing
remains workplace stuffed with commuting
lawyers and accountants
they've used article 4 directions to
prevent anyone turning it back
into dwellings the windfall from
business rates
means that they prefer old-fashioned
zoning
the most effective planet-saving reforms
will be to prevent commercial centres
and to spread live work across the
entirety of london
instead we are once again pursuing
outmoded
and outdated visions or
fantasies as london-wide protests by
ordinary working people
are calling them our capital is a
success
because people inhabit it there is
no commercial ghetto rotting away as in
so many other british cities
people live right by the largest
shopping centres
a few years ago khan wanted to
pedestrianize oxford street
if that had happened every
diesel-powered vehicle
that rumbles along it would have gone to
pump out its fumes
into the back streets where children
sleep
he was thwarted by the marylebone
association
who went to the voters on this single
issue
so if londoners want to get rid of those
who think that a pandemic gives them an
excuse to reorder their ten square miles
of local borough
and save the entire planet then
elect them out most of them are hanging
on
by less than 100 votes but
don't blame the mayor alone for this
failed scheme
after spending oodles of cash he's now
decided
to open the houston road again
it was all just an experiment
nobody wanted to bike in his new lane
in mind his cause has been embraced by
local
councils the graze inn
road is next up for works
that was great reece jones and now toby
young
one of the things i hadn't anticipated
about the pandemic is that it would turn
me into
an english nationalist at the time of
writing
the governments of scotland wales and
northern ireland
have decided to place their countries
under various forms of lockdown
while number 10 has stopped short of
imposing one on england
with some tier 3 hotspots the
explanation for this divergence is
simple
the scottish welsh and northern irish
executives
don't need to worry about the economic
harm the lockdowns will cause
because they know that westminster will
come to their rescue
boris by contrast can't afford to be so
reckless
because england has no equivalent sugar
daddy
the devolved nations are acting like
irresponsible students
running up massive debts on their credit
cards because they can count on the bank
of mum and dad
to bail them out actually it's even
worse than that in scotland's case
because one of nicolas sturgeon's
reasons for placing so much of the
country
under virtual house arrest is to whip up
nationalist sentiment
she wants to position herself as a
responsible grown-up
doing what's necessary to keep her
people safe in contrast to the
bumbling buffoon in westminster not only
will that
help the snp in the forthcoming
elections to the scottish parliament
it will also make a nationalist victory
more likely in the
inevitable second referendum the irony
of course
is that if the snp had won the first
referendum
sturgeon wouldn't be able to indulge in
this ruinously expensive virtue
signaling
with independence would have come a
modicum of fiscal responsibility
one of the better arguments for granting
the free spending nationalists their
wish
the actions of welsh first minister mark
drakeford
are scarcely any more explicable his
decision had
nothing to do with rising case numbers
hospital admissions or deaths
daily cases by specimen date plateaued
in wales last week
as have the number of cobit 19 patients
in critical care
daily deaths from covid peaked at 11 on
the 7th of october
and haven't climbed above single digits
since the cumulative death toll in wales
is 1722 which is about
four percent of the total in england no
the reason the welsh labor leader
has imposed these draconian restrictions
is to ratchet up the pressure on boris
and make it more difficult for him to
avoid imposing a
two-week circuit breaker thereby
enhancing the standing of kierstama
who called for one last week drakeford
can afford to play
politics with his own people's
livelihoods because he knows that boris
the man he's doing his best to embarrass
will have to pick up the pieces
all of which has left me feeling like an
angry red-faced
gammon up until now i haven't minded
subsidizing our lower-income neighbors
even though they've never exhibited the
slightest flicker of gratitude
i know from my involvement with various
good causes
that the beneficiaries of charitable
giving often
resent their dependence on you you do it
because it's the right thing to do
not because you want them to doff their
caps in appreciation
but for the devolved nations to take our
money and then use it to finance a
campaign to make
england look selfish and irresponsible
has pushed me over the edge
it's one thing to be resented by the
people you're supporting
financially but for them to be
self-righteously looking down their
noses at you
as they sweep your money into their
pockets is a bit much
it's like being the parent of three
teenagers who are permanently stuck in
the sanctimonious
holier-than-thou phase i haven't quite
given up
on unionism i still think we're better
off together
and i worry what will become of scotland
and wales if we were to part
so i think we should give them a choice
we hold referendums in
all three devolved nations and say look
devolution's not working
the english can't continue bankrolling
you if you're just going to set fire to
the money
in a misguided effort to make yourselves
look better than us
either you abandon this sophomoric
pretense of independence and
throw in your lot with us or you become
separate sovereign states
entirely responsible for your own
affairs i hope they choose to remain in
the uk
i really do but if they embrace full
independence
that would be better than this
unworkable halfway house
that was toby young and finally cosmo
landersman
thanks to a combination of nighttime
curfews social distancing rules
pubs closing restaurants failing the
rule of six
and compulsory mask wearing that basic
and necessary human need for people to
meet for a drink
has never been so difficult now
with the government's new three-tier
covert strategy in place
anyone at any moment could find their
local pub shut
their parties cancelled and all forms of
indoor mixing prohibited
millions in the uk are already living
under these restrictions
it's a fair bet that millions more will
soon join them
and if the government gives in to
demands for a circuit breaker
a short-term lockdown it would in effect
totally suspend
social drinking as we know it in the
wake of these restrictions
a disgruntled friend of mine spoke for
many when he said to me
what the hell are we supposed to do
drink on our own
yes you should try it i said when i told
him that i discovered during the first
lockdown back in march
that solitary drinking contrary to
popular thinking
is one of life's great pleasures he
looked concerned and said
are you okay want to talk about anything
we solitary drinkers we prefer to be
called solo drinkers
have always been stigmatized drinking on
your own is seen by the medical
profession as a sign of such
mental health problems as depression and
alcoholism
and the public at large regards solo
drinking with suspicion
particularly when it comes to men it's
what sad lonely men do
sad men in smelly rooms sad sloshed men
watching porn and drinking
cheap wine sad lonely depressed men
sending tweets they will regret in the
morning sad men
who weep themselves to sleep but nothing
could be further from the truth
at least for me i can just sit with a
nice cold martini and sinatra in the
background and just chill
no noisy pub with poor service no smoky
parties where you can never find a drink
and there's none of that bullying talk
of go on have another one don't be so
boring
plus you don't have to try and make
clever amusing chit-chat for other
people
i don't like to drink in public because
i get drunk so easily
i always wanted to be a tough hard
drinking journal like mailer or
hemingway
but when it comes to booze i'm a bambi
i just have one baby sham and i'm blotto
two drinks and i'm over the moon and
under the table
three and i'm under the hostess so i'll
do my drinking on my own thanks
solo drinking has its practical
advantages as well
it's much cheaper drinking on your own
because you don't have to buy endless
rounds of drinks
and at the end of the evening you don't
have to get that expensive cap home
because you can just pass out on your
sofa perfect
and best of all the only drunken boar
you have to suffer
as a solo drinker is yourself so man up
and drink up on your own that is you'll
feel liberated from that dependence on
needing other people around
to enjoy a drink after all you can enjoy
listening to music on your own
or eating a good meal on your own so why
not drinking on your own
cheers that was cosmo landersman thanks
for listening to this episode of
spectator out loud
and do join us again next week
you